vous vous êtes pourrez vous aimez ce
clip lui maxime n'avait pas échangé
expliquer et surtout justifier alléger
j'aime ce clip parce qu'il va marquer
l'histoire de la musique mais ça vous
pouvez pas comprendre le chanteur et
danseur et le metteur en scène sont
extraordinaires c'est une puissance
folle artistiquement c'est parfait et ça
dénonce les dérives de la société
américaine c'est faux c'est faux c'est
une calomnie c'est une allégorie la
violence laquelle la les auteurs
justifient la violence par la violence
je trouve ça assez et l'acceptable c'est
gratuit c'est injustifié et en plus de
ça le vrai problème c'est qu'il peut y
avoir une multiples interprétations de
ces faits extrêmement honteux de plus en
libre accès sur youtube vos lacunes en
histoire sont rédhibitoires
ce clip il dénonce l' esclavage les
auteurs ne veulent pas justifié leur
démarche mais il dit simplement ça
normalise le fait d'être noir
vous avez vu la scène avec les poulets
de vue vous l'avez vu vous savez ce que
c'est les poulets fait vous l'avez vu ou
pas la scène avec les poulets
l'extraordinaire il ya deux poulets qui
apparaissent ya à ce moment là des
jeunes qui tire avec un canon à billets
ça dénonce le fait que les jeunes
américains peuvent s'enrichir en vampire
la cocaïne
c'est une dénonciation tout est dans ce
clip maintenant le producteur et l'a dit
lui même
nous ne sommes pas aussi cérébraux que
les gens le pensent c'est à dire que eux
mêmes ne savent pas le message qu'il
envoie de plus ce genre de clip et
regarder sur internet par des enfants
sauf ça c'est honteux mais ça dénonce la
violence y compris des noirs envers les
noirs y compris contre le lobby des
armes aux états unis c'est un clip
salutaire vous n'êtes pas assez
intelligent pour le comprend alors c'est
vrai alors si on dénonce la violence par
la violence
comme une tendance excusez moi rien
n'oblige une et rien ne garantit que
cette dénonciation virtuels deviennent
réelles alors franchement c'est en
l'occurrence le clip n'est pas virtuel
du tour d'italie oui totalement concret
on va quand même voir le sondage est ce
que gilles vous a convaincu ou est ce
que on n'est pas supposé des bars et une
bonne course mais il est quand même en
tête mais quand même en scène absolument
il a raison de souligner de l'ambiguïté
absolue pour moi du clip assure par pas
parfaitement l'anglais cia pas le
décodage des rien on voit juste jouer
les écolages qui sous prétexte qu'on est
tous abasourdis fournit tout avec une
pipe à la bouche
[Applaudissements]
je suis d'accord avec jets parce que ça
d'être vraiment la violence qui se passe
aux etats unis la réalité il ya des
maîtres tous les jours aux etats-unis
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il ya une une
ride excessive au texas on a quasiment
l'impression que ça encourage son nom à
cette question